now it is time for the uplift at eight
where we share stories that will bring
you some joy to your day
and today's story is about the ultimate
best friend kaylee shorts went above and
beyond to make sure she captured her
best friend's engagement on camera you
know what people will do sometimes to
get that shot right off somebody
proposing take a look at this this is
kaylee
[Laughter]
she's dressed up as a bush
once i know she went out and literally
found a bush costume i guess and hid in
the actual bushes to make sure she got
candid photos of ryan proposing the
nicolette kaylee and ryan even practiced
the proposal to make sure it would be
just right nicolette said it was perfect
and she was thrilled kaylee got to be
there and take photos of the big moment
watch this
i just turned around and
a walking bush came towards me and
kaylee came out of the bushes and hugged
us and she was crying and everybody was
crying it was so much fun
i'd go running if i saw bush like
walking towards me uh but they recently
posted the video of kaylee surprise on
tick tock and of course it went viral
ryan and nicolette plan to get married
in october congratulations as for the
bush suit kelly says it will stay in her
closet to remember the special day
that's what friends are for
i love it